У Кельні відкрився один з найсучасніших у Європі
всепогодний випробувальний центр для автівок.
Давайте зазирнемо, зокрема в лабораторію,
де симулюється перебування на великій висоті.
Цей пристрій може генерувати швидкість вітру
до 250 км/год,
а також імітувати тиск повітря
на висоті до 5200 метрів.
Отже тут, більш екстремальні умови,
ніж на найвищий вершині Європи - Монблані.
Це унікальна лабораторія.
Також тут досліджують, як себе поведе мастило
та інші рідини в автівці за таких  зовнішніх умов.
Наступна камера - це не просто аеродинамічний тунель,
а багатофункціональна камера з повітродувним пристроєм,
роликовим випробувальним стендом
та кондиціонуванням  повітря.
Теплообмінний пристрій може регулювати температуру.
Форсунки з  паровими насадками забезпечують за потреби високу вологість.
Для тестування транспортного засобу,
який може бути оснащений усіма необхідними датчиками вимірювання,
може знадобитися до двох тижнів.
Далі йдуть функціональні випробування,
в яких приблизно 350 датчиків
передають дані про температуру та тиск.
Наша основна увага зосереджена переважно на внутрішньому кондиціонуванні.
Треба бути впевненим в комфорті для замовника,
а також в охолодженні силового агрегату.
Які насправді показники витривалості автомобіля?
Чи здатен він продемонструвати те, що було обчислене заздалегідь?
Порівняно з випробуваннями на природі, лабораторні тести
проходять набагато швидше і їх можна повторювати багато разів.
Нова тестова лабораторія пропонує багато можливостей
і вона потужніша за попередні,
однак тести у приміщенні не можуть замінити
випробування в реальних умовах.
Те, що ми робимо, звичайно, попередньо було скорельовано
з випробуваннями в реальних умовах.
Ми відправляли автівки на південь Іспанії, відправляли до Італії,
на гору Ґрос-Ґлокнер, після чого вимірювали дані,
потім відновлювали їх у камерах,
щоб перевірити  повторно, наскільки вони різняться.
Підемо до наступного аеродинамічного тунелю.
Після натискання кнопки тестовий автомобіль отримує тут холодний душ.
У новому центрі працюють близько 60 інженерів-випробувачів
та кваліфікованих робітників.
Ми досліджуємо з різною швидкістю з різною кількістю води,
як поводять себе склоочисники, або що може статися,
якщо хтось відкриє вікно під час водіння у дощ,
скільки води потрапляє в салон автомобіля.
Згодом будуть інші випробування,
де ми потім перевіримо, чи може вода потрапляти у двигун,
що, звичайно, було б дуже погано.
У наступній камері справжня сушарка.
І тут  гаряче: 40 градусів за Цельсієм.
Ця кімната - одна з двох так званих камер кондиціонування.
Вони використовуються, передусім, для перевірки нагрівання автомобілів
або для того, щоб випробувати їх на охолодження.
Ці крайності можна знайти у Кельні за сусідніми дверями навпроти.
Говорячи лише про технічні параметри випробувального центру,
можна сказати, що він є найхолоднішим і водночас
найспекотнішим та найвищим місцем у Західній Європі.
Таким чином, навіть якщо це літо,
можна симулювати і розбирати класичні зимові проблеми.
Форд вклав у новий випробувальний центр 70 мільйонів євро.
Одночасно у різних умовах у ньому можуть тестувати 10 автівок.